[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEREMY OAKEY: So
I'm Jeremy Oakey.
I am the Senior Director of
Product Management with Cisco.
I've specifically been
working very closely--
you may have heard in the
keynote David Goeckeler
talking about we've
been working with Google
for the last year
on a joint solution
that we've been talking about.
We're going to talk about
that in some detail today.
And so I've been running that
technical program as well.
So let me start with
a tale of innovation.
We start usually talking about
dev teams and two pizza box
teams.
Well, I couldn't
find a pizza graphic
on our internal site that was
legal and official to use,
so I had to change
up a little bit.
So let's talk about a
tale of innovation here.
I have some executives.
They're brainstorming in
an undisclosed location,
nice views, probably a
round of golf afterwards.
They come up with a great
idea of what they want
to do soon in this Cloud world.
After the idea's agreed upon,
they all call their kids
and see if their kids
can develop for them.
Actually, they call the
talented architects,
they meet, discuss
the plan, and they
see if they can deliver on
what the executives want to do.
So now we have an innovation
team of devs that gets to work,
minus the pizza.
So how familiar is
this to many of you?
How many of you have innovation
teams now working internally
on Cloud, native, micro
services, et cetera?
Show of hands.
OK.
We see this a lot.
Doesn't really change the
fact that you probably still
have all the kind of classical
IT that runs your business
and makes money.
But you've got this
new team that's
working on all the new
and exciting stuff.
So what have we
kind of announced
between Cisco and Google?
Really, a consistent
deployment environment.
Deploy, develop and deploy
anywhere, secure, consistent
hybrid environment,
innovation on your own terms.
So that's the end
of the marketing.
Let's get into what
this actually means.
So I am part one of probably
a multi-part act here today.
Since we only have 45, 50
minutes and breakout sessions,
we've kind of broken
into multiple pieces.
So first and
foremost, later today,
go to the first one today
because it's my boss.
Tell him I did a good job.
Tomorrow we actually have
a technical deep dive
that's both Cisco and
Google presenting.
It's going to be a lot
talking about what we're
going to talk about
now, but leaning more
into Istio and what we're
working with Google on there.
And on the-- actually,
I put the arrow
by the wrong thing
that's bad on me.
I/O 284 is the
second part of this
that's going more into
the on premise Kubernetes,
and the production grade
Kubernetes environments.
So that's at 10:20 on Thursday.
I put the chevron
by the wrong one.
So we've been talking
about this for a while.
How many of you heard about
this since last August
when we announced it
publicly with Google?
Anyone been following
this since August?
A few, about 20%.
OK.
So we announced what we were
doing with Google in October.
We have our
multi-cloud portfolio,
which is Cisco's
bigger story about how
we work with all
the many products
that Cisco has to
connect clouds.
We launched container platform
in Cisco Live Barcelona
in January.
Stealth Watch Cloud now supports
Google VPC flow logs in March.
In May at KubeCon, we
announced both our app dynamics
application performance
management products supporting
Kubernetes, and Cloud Center,
our Cloud management product,
also supporting Kubernetes.
So all these things have
been the incremental progress
we've been making.
So it may seem that a
long time ago October was.
But we've had a lot of
incremental progress
that lead us to what the total
solution is that you just heard
onstage, shipping next month.
So a little detail what it
is for half of you that maybe
haven't heard about this.
So Cisco Hybrid Cloud
Platform for Google Cloud,
official name.
You may see it called CHCP
in acronym some places.
The on premise and
Google Cloud that
has a consistent environment
capability delivering security,
hybrid cloud management,
service mesh, and networking,
connecting what Google
does well in the Cloud
and what Cisco does
well on premise.
So what does that look like
from component perspective?
So let's start with
on Google Cloud.
Obviously you have all
the services and things
in Google Cloud.
Starts with Google Kubernetes
engine, doesn't replace that.
You also have a
number of services.
Today Google advertises
platform services, six of them,
through open service broker,
out to the other areas
such as an on
premise environment.
So moving to the
left, what do we have?
Google Apigee.
I want to have RESTful
API interfaces.
That innovation team that's
working is familiar with REST.
Your mainframe or some of
your legacy applications
may not actually
talk RESTful API.
Even if they do, perhaps
there are some other nuances
we'll get into in a minute when
we talk about that use case.
So I have those existing
services on premise.
Maybe I want to run
Kubernetes on premise.
My security officer, my
application, data gravity,
I need something on premise.
But I still want it
to be Kubernetes.
But I want it to be
production ready.
What do I want to
run it on top of?
Cisco sells hyper converged
and our traditional converged
infrastructure, so
HyperFlex and also software
defined networking.
So a little bit
more specifically,
what are we doing
in the products?
So on Google Cloud,
we are going to be
offering in August the Cisco CSR
1000v Virtual Router on Google
Cloud to connect that consistent
connectivity between on premise
and Cloud.
This is Cisco's
kind of heritage.
We obviously have lots of
other products besides.
So it could be firewalls,
it could be physical ASRs,
CSI, ISR routers.
It could also be that you have
a Cisco device on one side
and you want to connect a
Google Cloud VPN on the other,
also supported
the configuration.
Or you could be using a
connectivity partner that's
using low latency, high
throughput Google Cloud
Interconnect.
So those are all
supported scenarios.
I want a consistent
security experience, so
combination of firewalls
and defense and depth.
That isn't enough
in a Cloud world.
We can do things like
intrusion prevention,
but what happens when half the
traffic goes off to the Cloud?
So things like
StealthWatch Cloud.
We have sensors on
premise, sensors on GKE,
and also VPC flow logs so that
we have a full visibility,
because we have an
extended trust model now
on the security.
And then coming down onto
the Cisco container platform,
having the option to run Istio
either on Cisco container
platform or GKE, but
also Istio's promise--
you saw some demos
in the keynote
showing its automatic
visibility of both sides.
So Cisco's been working
very closely with Google
to get that multi-Cloud,
multi-site capability
integrated into Istio because
that's important to us,
especially.
Contiv is our container
networking technology
that then sits on top
of the physical assets.
So couple of use cases.
We'll get very specific now.
I mentioned Apigee on premise.
So Google Apigee is also sold
as a software as a service
offering, but maybe you want it
on premise for various reasons.
So we, in the solution,
are supporting deploying
Apigee Edge on premise.
And why would you need that?
Maybe your application already
does have RESTful APIs.
Maybe it doesn't.
So first and foremost,
giving a RESTful interface
on premise to things that
might completely live out
in the Cloud, your mainframe,
your physical database assets.
But more importantly, it also
can do telemetry, control,
who should be able to
access it, reporting.
Maybe you want to charge.
The data you have on
premise is valuable to you.
Apigee can create a front
end so that you can actually
charge someone every time
they pull from your API,
so start to monetize
your data on premise.
And maybe that's your
service all in itself
is getting something
out past your firewall
in a very controlled RESTful API
way and making money from it.
So a second use case.
I have an application
on premise I want
to extend out into the Cloud.
The couple of technical
sessions I mentioned
that are going to follow up are
going to actually demo this use
case very specifically.
But say, for example, you
have an application on premise
and your customers can
put in feedback on it.
Wouldn't it be nice to do
customer sentiment analytics?
Do you want to own that
and operate that service?
Perhaps not.
You can go ahead
and use services
like Pub/Sub, Cloud Span,
or BigQuery, Big Tables,
et cetera from Google.
And so the on
premise application
gets extensibility
into the public Cloud
to get those additional platform
services through open service
broker and service
catalog, which
are built into the on premise
Cisco container platform.
Lastly, the most common use
case we hear from customers.
Maybe you want dev on
public Cloud, Google Cloud,
and you want dev
on private Cloud.
Really, it's a choice,
customers are choosing
to run things in various ways.
One team may operate very
differently than another
as well.
One size doesn't fit all.
So I want to have a
100% upstream Kubernetes
environment.
I mentioned the innovation team.
So your innovation team
also was off in a corner
running Kubernetes
on their laptop,
writing services, re-platforming
your applications,
and creating this new
thing that the executives
asked for and envisioned.
Who takes the phone
call Friday night at 2
AM when the Kubernetes
application doesn't work?
How many of you guys are all
production ops, IT ops kind
of folks, and not developers?
Raised hands.
Who's not developers
in the room?
There's a lot of developers.
All right.
So I'm talking to
you IT ops guys.
You know that you take the call
at 2:00 AM when it's broken.
So some of you may not even
be familiar with Kubernetes.
It's the world that
the developers are in,
they're platforming, they're
testing, they're developing,
they're pushing code,
they're doing things
like Agilent and CICD,
continuous integration
continuous deployment.
And then they come
to you and say I'd
like to take this production.
And you start asking
the obvious questions.
Is it secure?
Does it scale?
Is it documented?
Who needs access to it?
All the things that developers
don't necessarily care about.
Security, developers
usually deliver outcomes.
Security oftentimes isn't
built into the application.
I think we're starting to see
that change with regulations
like GDPR.
We're starting to have to build
more into the application.
But we still need also
that umbrella of security
that covers everything.
So really, this use case,
and what we're working on
is you need to be
able to deploy.
The developers need to have
something they can depend on.
It needs be production ready.
And who do you
have to support you
when it's broken in the
middle of the night?
So this is a lot of
open source technology.
So we're wrapping
this with support.
So really, that's
the biggest thing
I think that Google and
Cisco have been working on,
mostly, is Cisco has
an enterprise class
technical support capability.
You may already have
a lot of products
from Cisco, routers, switches,
firewalls, other software
products, and you
know you can call
Cisco 24/7 around
the clock and you'll
get someone who will help
you and prioritize it and get
it fixed for you.
So that's what we're
bringing to this.
We also, obviously,
have a partner ecosystem
that supports this and
can design and install it.
So I mentioned secure.
We need to start doing things
like proactive security, threat
detection.
Integrated VPN and connectivity
is one bit, but also
behavioral analysis.
I'm going to talk specifically
now about StealthWatch Cloud.
So those of you who
haven't seen it,
this is kind of a StealthWatch
Cloud user interface.
I come into a dashboard.
This is a SaaS
offering from Cisco.
So you don't have to worry
about running the platform.
You just deploy the sensors
and consume the intelligence
analytics that the
platform provides.
I see that I have a number
of sensors deployed.
So this happened to be from
Cisco Live US last month.
I have different kind
of workers deployed.
I have a Google
Kubernetes environment
I have sensors deployed to.
I have some VM ware.
How many of you think that
your container applications are
never going to talk
to anything that's
your old applications, your
virtuals, your physical?
I don't think that.
I think for a while
we're actually
going to be running
in this composite mode
where the new
applications need to talk
to the other
applications that haven't
been re-plaformed
and modernized yet.
So we have our existing
data center assets
we need to start getting
technical and security
telemetry from.
And then finally,
Google Cloud Platform
has VPC flow log
support now that
has come out and been released.
And so we have the ability
to see the flow logs.
The data, you can't see
underneath the Cloud
is exposed to the flow
logs, and StealthWatch Cloud
picks that up.
So what does that mean?
I get visualization.
Who's talking to who?
How are they talking?
What kind of alerts, what
kind of connectivity?
How many observations
are we making?
Looking at networks, talking
to what kind of traffic
are they exchanging?
How many connections are active?
Looking at the heuristics
and past performance--
the last 24 hours I've had
this kind of traffic pattern--
and you can see there's
check boxes where
maybe events have occurred
that you want to click into.
So important thing.
Difference from a firewall, or
like an intrusion prevention
system, the models are taking
all these various inputs
we just described.
They're then correlating
it with entity behavior.
A firewall may say
this country can never
talk to me because I don't
do business in that country.
Or I have a pattern match, and
intrusion prevention oftentimes
looks at a pattern, and you tend
to get a lot of false positives
sometimes as that
pattern changes.
But wouldn't you like
to know, every day
I get these kind of
connections, and I then
send the connection
off to Google,
and the response back
from Google Cloud
is normally one packet that's
20 kilobytes of an answer.
What happens if that
behavior changed?
All of a sudden I have a
million packets going out
to Google Cloud and the
response is now 40k or 100k.
The behavior changed.
So using kind of a
heuristic pattern
matching and the
behavior analysis,
we're looking at the security
to say something's different.
So this isn't just
simply firewalls
and intrusion prevention.
And what do you kind of get?
Now I actually have
very actionable alerts.
Hey, people who don't
normally access this system
have tried to do SSH
into your GKE clusters.
Drill into it.
It's been accessed from a
country that doesn't normally
exist.
Maybe this was a change
in your business.
You'll be able to quickly go
and accept this or mark this
as something that's actionable.
If it's something that's
normal, your business patterns
have changed, your security
ops folks click this
and say this is normal.
The behavior no longer
recognizes this as an anomaly.
So we have lots of information.
The countries will load
in with the IP addresses.
Everything is applicable
in here to drill in.
What kind of endpoints?
What kind of activity do we
have going through the system?
So this shows you
behavior of endpoints,
and when your peak times
in your business are.
So this is an
example of the inputs
that are used in the model
and the behavior analysis.
What kind of traffic do we
see, what kind of ins and outs?
How many connections?
Internal devices versus
extrernal devices?
So it's graphing
all that for you
and showing what's occurring.
Now how many are very familiar
with Kubernetes in this room?
Again, about half, 2/3.
All right.
So how many of you
prefer the CLI?
For those of you who aren't
familiar with Kubernetes,
managing via
Kubernetes means you're
using kubectl, kube control.
And these are the kind
of commands you use
to manipulate the environment.
So let's hop into
some demos here
and kind of show
you what we think
is a little bit different
about what we're doing.
So your innovation
team may be familiar.
You don't want to replace their
familiarity with those CLI
commands.
But I mentioned we now
have two sets of operators.
I have a development team whose
job is delivering outcomes.
I have an operations
team whose job
is to deliver a secure, stable.
Production grade environment.
So with Cisco container
platform on premise,
I can actually do things
like deploy clusters.
So I have multiple
clusters here.
Let's make sure I'm
still logged in.
So I have four clusters
here I've created.
So container platform,
first and foremost,
is a multi-cluster
management platform.
I can create and destroy
clusters via API, via CLI,
via user interface here.
So your IT ops folks
can be the people
who create, Kubernetes these
environments on premise.
This also can be extended out.
Developers could create
and destroy their own.
Your scripting, your automation
could create and destroy it.
One of the hard things
about Kubernetes,
though, once it's deployed also,
is the upgrades and management
and logging and support of it.
So container
platform specifically
shows you the cluster,
gives you an interface.
I can see how many
master nodes I
have working in the
environment, how they're set up.
I can then do
something interesting.
I now have kind of a
multi-tenant environment,
if you will.
I'm the IT operator, I
see all the clusters.
I now have a
dashboard that shows
me the help, the logging, the
Kubernetes cluster management
of the entire system.
I now, though, can
provide subsets.
I can provide just a Kubernetes
cluster to a dev team.
So no longer is
the innovation team
in the back corner on a
laptop running mini kube
or on an environment
that's not connected
to what can get
out to the internet
and to the public Cloud.
Now I have an environment
I can expose to them.
So they can very quickly
download a token.
And I can actually
jump over into,
if they're very familiar
with Kubernetes--
let me re-pull in that token I
saved from container platform
and log in.
If they're very familiar with
the Kubernetes environment,
they're still seeing Kubernetes.
You're now giving
them, basically,
a tenancy in an
environment that's managed
by production operations.
They can now be the
support organization.
So if you need distributed
roles, you can do that.
If IT ops is going to
completely take it over,
you still can learn and
see and use Kubernetes.
So all the things you'd
normally see in Kubernetes
are being managed by
Cisco container platform.
So let's talk a little
bit about an application.
I think you saw in the
keynote that Google's passion
about hipster stuff.
Well, at Cisco, we're
passionate about socks.
Holey socks.
What do we have ?
We have lots of socks here.
Super socks, color socks,
cross socks, et cetera.
So this is an application
my innovation team wrote.
And we're going to run into
our cloud management platform
product.
So when the developers
were deploying this,
they may have
deployed this using
YAML files, text
files that describe
what the deployment looks like,
how the configuration should
work.
In Cisco, we also have a visual
cloud management product.
So let me describe it.
A couple of things.
The Thursday session
is going to go
under a lot more detail on both
Container Platform and Cloud
Center.
But what I have here is a drag
and drop topology capability.
Maybe, for example,
your innovation team
is really good at deploying
their specific application.
But you have another
team that maybe
is the experts in
Cassandra, or your NoSQL,
or your relational database, or
your production load balancers.
So one team may not
have the whole set
of ingredients it takes to
make the system production.
Therefore, we have, on the left,
all the various components,
and we're capturing the
organizational best practices
and automation of all
the best components.
Think of these like widgets.
You may want a blue car,
you may want a red plane.
We might share some widgets.
On the left is all the widgets.
In the middle is where
we're dragging them
into the outcome, the
blue car or the red plane.
So this is my socks application.
Lots of little micro
services, containers.
This also could mix in.
Maybe I need to put
in a very traditional
virtual machine-based
message bus,
or I want to drag out
an operating system
because I need a jump
box or something.
Or I need to drag out
an NFS file system.
So the drag and drop
capability environment
means that people
who don't necessarily
know as much about
these individual widgets
may still be able to get the
expert organizational knowledge
and add it to their outcome.
So now I have something
that's reusable.
And so when we talk about I
want to be able to deploy this,
dev wants this on
Google Cloud, prod
wants this on the internal
container platform environment,
or vice versa.
So what we have in CLI and YAML
files is technically accurate,
but it may not also
have guardrails.
So this system also
gives the ability
to have tag-based governance.
Maybe devs don't know
prod should go here
and dev should go there,
or stage also goes here.
Or maybe they don't know that
data classification needs
to go over an encrypted
path, and non-PCI maybe
doesn't have to go over it.
So those are the kind of things,
the non-technical guardrails,
if you will, that a Cloud
management platform adds
into the technical
capability the innovation
team's delivering.
So when I come and look
at these deployments,
the user can now self-serve,
see the number of deployments.
I have a number of things here.
I have an Istio deployment.
My socks application that
I showed you earlier,
I've deployed it.
So the developer
can actually see.
Or this could be the admin.
Who deployed it,
when did they deploy
it, how much is it
costing them, what's
the health of all the
different components?
Things like can I add
more, can I scale them?
All of this can be done via user
interface, via command line,
or via APIs.
So for example, App Dynamics
or the other APM system
you use of choice may be
monitoring this application
now, looking at the health
in the user experience.
And would that application need
to be written to go and find
the innovation guys
know their YAML file
and know how to scale
and add additional nodes
if the middleware tier is slow,
or if the store itself, the web
server, is slow?
Perhaps, but we already have a
lot of those integrations built
into the system.
Also, when you call Friday night
at 2:00 AM because it's broken,
this is what the Cisco
Technical Assistance Center,
working with Google,
will actually
help you fix when it's broken.
So all the services
and visibility
is exposed to everyone,
not just the innovation
team that happens to be the
container and Kubernetes
experts.
And ultimately we get it
all in a nice dashboard that
shows us what's it costing us,
how much are we running, how
often, where all of the
different various clouds
we're using, et cetera.
So let's talk a little bit
about how this works in practice
and some of the other
problems we have
with enterprise applications.
So over the last
couple of months,
Google and Cisco and SAP have
been working very closely
together.
So SAP is launching Data Hub.
Many of you may
be SAP HANA users.
They just had their SFP
SAPPHIRE Conference.
So they've been announcing
Data Hub and their HANA data
management platform.
This is a great example of
an enterprise application.
So Cisco and Google
are also working
with these types of
enterprise providers
because they're modernizing
their platforms and software
to use Cloud native and
container concepts as well.
So SAP Data Hub has
been completely built
on top of Kubernetes.
Now I'm not going to go
into too much detail.
I think SAP is here and has
a session this week as well.
But really, we're describing
a hybrid environment now.
I have a data gravity
problem oftentimes.
Data Hub is very specifically
looking at AI and ML,
streams and databases,
apps with big data,
object stores and IOT devices.
Those may all be running
out in Google Cloud
they may want to
bring all of that back
and coordinate it with ERP data,
customer data, sales data, et.
Cetera so SAP Data
Hub has components
that are containerized that can
run both on GKE and on Cisco
container platform on premise.
Depends on where your data is.
Some customers may have
more data on premise
that they're actually
trying to ship out.
Other customers may
have a lot that's
being generated
outside that they're
trying to bring in and do
the analysis on premise.
So a good example of how
we're working with this
ecosystem to certify and support
these enterprise applications
on top of the joint solution
between Cisco and Google.
All right.
So kind of summarize
what we're doing
and what you'll see in
the next couple sessions.
One, we're integrating.
So some of the
complexity that we're not
going to go into here, but
on the Thursday session,
is what are we doing southbound?
Do you need persistent storage?
So Cisco has already done the
integration with the HyperFlex
platform to be able to have
persistent storage as well
as with third parties, so
that if you need to save data,
you actually have access
to that saved data.
How do I connect into the
network, both physical
and container networking?
That's built into
container platform.
How do I tie into
the Management We're
providing a management
interface that
has a holistic view of IT ops.
And then still,
we're not changing.
I've showed you kind of
Cisco's view of the CICD,
where maybe the continuous
integration is Jenkins.
And then we're using
Cloud Center Deploy
as the container's deployment.
But because I said I'm
given the developers
a consistent Kubernetes
environment that they can still
access just like they
were familiar with,
if they have their
own CICD pipeline,
it's still 100%
compatible with this.
I think Google started talking
about a Google Cloud-based
build environment would
also be able to talk
to this environment.
So we're not forcing
customers or development teams
to change the way they operate.
If you have something you
like that talks to Kubernetes
directly and that
works, the platform
just gives you production
grade and still gives you
Kubernetes access to it.
So all the open source
API software and tools
are completely
exposed 100% upstream.
So it's optimized.
Obviously working very
closely with Google Cloud.
We're testing the
open service broker.
We're working to
contribute to Istio
and make sure that that works
both on premise and in Google
Cloud.
And then the support model is
completely wrapped by someone
you can call Friday at
2:00 AM to take your call.
So this can be a
little complicated.
We obviously have partners,
and Cisco ourselves,
that can deliver services
to help make all this work.
Simply, this is an
example of a quick start
service we offer today.
Install all the environment
stuff on premise.
That's what's in
blue on the left.
Maybe those use cases you saw
help you work with those use
cases, set up the environment.
The innovation
team in the corner
might need help kind of bringing
what they have into your team.
So these services can help
deliver that capability
quickly.
So we have lots of demos.
Cisco has a big booth
on the show floor.
Just kind of show you, we
have some sample applications
we're using in the demo booth.
If you want to see
something very specifically
or dive into your
specific use cases,
the folks there have been
involved very heavily
in the solution.
So they have the ability to kind
of show you what this looks.
Like they have some nice
3D demos I'm showing you.
They'll click through.
So this is kind of
what it looks like.
Very similar, but they
have a nice, cool 3D
view to click through.
How many of you guys have heard
of the Cisco Google Challenge?
It was in a blog post yesterday.
It may not be talked
about too much.
Anyone heard about it yet?
Few enthusiastic hands.
All right.
So if you don't know what
it is, Cisco and Google
are working together
to create a challenge.
This is an event that's going
to run for the next few months.
If you go to this URL
you can learn about it.
I've already seen some students
say, are students eligible?
Sure.
But we'd like to see some
customers and partners and dev
teams and others.
It's a great way for
you to start one,
getting access to this in these
environments for yourself.
Two, there's some real
money, some prizes.
I think the top three winners--
I know I run
container platforms--
I've donated three 20-node
one-year subscriptions.
I think there's some cash money.
There's some Google Cloud
credits and some other things.
So the winners
will be announced.
I think this runs all the way
into February, which is when
Cisco Live Barcelona occurs.
So you have months to
kind of read on this,
get excited, sign up.
But that URL is where
you can go learn more
about the Cisco
Google Challenge.
All right.
We also have-- there's our
booth that you can go visit
and all the places
you can follow us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]